This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. When you look at the partisan divisions in the United States and other countries, you see something curious. There's a bias, a double standard. It's always there, it pervades our society. It's not just that each side accuses the other of bias. Right-wing media isn't doing journalism, it's doing fan fiction. The left can insult people, the left can make outrageous statements, nothing happens.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。当你审视美国和其他国家的党派分歧时，你会发现一个奇怪的现象。存在一种偏见，一种双重标准。它无处不在，弥漫在我们的社会中。这不仅仅是双方都指责对方有偏见。右翼媒体不是在做新闻，而是在写同人小说。左翼可以侮辱人，左翼可以发表离谱的言论，却什么事也没有。
Oh, it's different on the right. They accuse one another of the same kinds of bias. All the staff members at the New York Times, Washington Post, CNN, MSNBC, they're like cornered, rabid rats. They've been selling us lies for so many years. The Americans who listen to Fox News and conservative talk radio are being lied to and manipulated every day. Each site says the other is blind to facts, blind to reason.
哦，右翼的情况则不同。他们互相指责对方存在同样性质的偏见。《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》、CNN、MSNBC的所有员工，就像被逼入绝境的狂犬。多年来他们一直在向我们兜售谎言。收听福克斯新闻和保守派谈话节目的美国人，每天都在被谎言欺骗和操纵。两边都说对方对事实视而不见，对理性盲目。
Look, we're taking on a Republican party that has rejected science, where the vast majority of Republican congressmen and senators do not even accept the reality of climate change. Let alone the need. This is a metaphor really for the left's entire program, which is built entirely on denying reality. They deny the reality of the legal immigration. They deny the reality of terrorism. They deny the reality of biological gender. You see the same thing in many other conflicts around the world. Each side accuses the other of inflexibility and ideological blindness.
听着，我们正在对抗一个排斥科学的共和党，在这个党里，绝大多数共和党国会议员甚至不接受气候变化是现实。更不用说这种需求了。这其实是左翼整个纲领的一个隐喻，该纲领完全建立在否定现实的基础之上。他们否认合法移民的现实。他们否认恐怖主义的现实。他们否认生物学性别的现实。你在世界各地的许多其他冲突中也会看到同样的事情。双方都指责对方死板和意识形态盲目。
Now, there are certainly situations where one side is right and the other is wrong. One side is biased and the other is not or at least less so. Our focus today though is not or at least less so. Our focus today though is not on specific controversies. Rather, we want to explore the psychological mechanisms that prompt us to judge our own behavior very differently than the behavior of other people. This week on Hidden Brain, the double standard inside our heads. On a daily basis, all of us evaluate others. We think about the claims of people who want to sell us something, we gauge the ideas of colleagues, we assess friends and family.
当然，在某些情况下，一方是对的，另一方是错的。一方有偏见，另一方没有，或者至少没那么严重。不过，我们今天的重点不在于具体的争议，或者至少不完全在于此。相反，我们想要探讨的是，是什么心理机制促使我们以截然不同的标准来评判自己的行为与他人的行为。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，探讨我们脑海中的双重标准。每天，我们所有人都在评估他人。我们会思考那些想向我们推销东西的人的主张，我们衡量同事的想法，我们评估朋友和家人。
We also regularly look into our own hearts and minds, we evaluate ourselves. At Princeton University, psychologists Emily Pronen has studied why our minds come to very different conclusions about ourselves and others. Emily Pronen, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. So a few years ago, Emily, you conducted an experiment where you brought volunteers into a lab and you told them about a range of different biases, you know, biases like the halo effect,
我们也经常审视自己的内心和思想，我们评估自己。在普林斯顿大学，心理学家艾米·普罗宁一直在研究为什么我们的头脑会对我们自己和他人得出截然不同的结论。艾米·普罗宁，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。那么几年前，艾米，你做过一个实验，你把志愿者请进实验室，向他们介绍了一系列不同的偏见，你知道的，比如光环效应这样的偏见，
where you see someone who's very beautiful and you assume this person must also be very intelligent, or a bias like confirmation bias, where we go looking for information that supports our pre-existing views. And you did something very interesting. You asked the volunteers whether they thought that they would fall prey to these biases. What did they tell you?
即当你看到一个非常漂亮的人时，你会假设这个人一定也非常聪明；或者像确认偏误这样的偏见，即我们去寻找支持我们既定观点的信息。你做了一件非常有趣的事。你问志愿者，他们是否认为自己会沦为这些偏见的牺牲品。他们对你说了什么？
We had students in a class so that they kind of all knew each other from being in the class together. And what we did is we described each bias just in a few sentences. We didn't use the word bias. We didn't want to make it sound like a negative thing so that people would say, that's bad. I don't do that. We just described it in neutral terms. Sometimes people do this, do you do this? And what we found is that people said, oh gee, other people do do that. That's so great. You put that into words like that. I see that all the time.
我们找了一班的学生，所以他们因为一起上过课而彼此认识。我们的做法是用几句话来描述每一种偏见。我们没有使用“偏见”这个词。我们不想让它听起来像是一件消极的事情，从而让人们说：“这不好，我才不那样。”我们只是用中立的术语来描述它。有时人们会这样做，你会这样做吗？我们发现人们说：“哦天哪，别人确实会那样做。太棒了。你把它用这样的词汇表达出来了。我经常看到这种情况。”
Someone's really attractive and then they think that person is great on every dimension. But me, I know I don't really do that. So what happened was people recognized the bias as something that people do, and they attributed it to other people, but they thought that they did it quite a bit less. And the same thing happens in so many different domains. If you asked me, do you evaluate the news fairly? Are you a good judge of policy? I'll tell you, of course I am, but I can see lots of biases in the people around me.
“有人非常有吸引力，然后他们就觉得那个人在方方面面都很棒。”但至于我，我知道我其实不那样。所以发生的事情是，人们把偏见识别为别人会做的事，并将其归咎于他人，但他们认为自己这么做的频率要低得多。在许多不同的领域也会发生同样的事情。如果你问我：“你对新闻的评估公平吗？你对政策的判断力好吗？”我会告诉你：“我当然是，但我能看到身边的人身上有很多偏见。”
Emily, you call this the bias blind spot. What do you mean by the term? The reason why I came to call it a bias blind spot is that a blind spot refers to a situation where you can see some things sort of all around you except in one place. Mm-hmm. And so the blind spot is seeing the bias in yourself, because it turns out that people could readily recognize these biases all around them. Let's look at some specific domains where the bias blind spot affects us. When it comes to ethics, we're all quick to see conflicts of interest in other people, but slow to see it when it comes to ourselves.
艾米，你把这称为偏见盲点。你这个术语是什么意思？我之所以称之为偏见盲点，是因为盲点指的是这样一种情况：你可以看到周围的许多事物，却唯独在一个地方看不到。嗯哼。所以盲点就是看不到自己身上的偏见，因为事实证明，人们可以很容易地认出周围的所有这些偏见。让我们来看看偏见盲点影响我们的几个具体领域。在道德方面，我们所有人都能很快发现别人身上的利益冲突，但在自己身上却很难察觉。
It's such a beautiful example. So, you know, doctors and gifts from the pharmaceutical industry, so people have studied this, and doctors will say, I'm not influenced by gifts. And oftentimes the gifts are small, right? They're like, you have a Pfizer pen or a tattoo paper. Sometimes the gifts are rather large. Like, we'd love to hear you come and give a talk on your research, you know, in the Caribbean, you know, we'll fly you over there, you know, in a private jet to give your talk. And I credit to the medical industry that I think, you know, they have really worked on trying to root this out
这是一个多么美丽的例子。所以，你知道的，医生和来自制药行业的礼物，人们对此进行过研究，医生会说：“我不会受到礼物的金钱影响。”通常礼物都很小，对吧？比如，你有一个辉瑞的笔或一个便签纸。有时礼物相当大。比如，“我们很想听你来做一个关于你的研究的演讲，在加勒比海，我们会用私人飞机把你接过去做演讲。”我认为医药行业真的在这方面努力根除它，这值得赞赏，
because they recognized it as a problem. So there's no longer free lunches for residents every day, you know, sponsored by various drug companies as far as I understand. But the point being that doctors said that they were not influenced by these gifts, but that other doctors were. So it's a perfect example of a conflict of interest not being recognized in self, but seen in others. The bias blind spot also affects how we think we are affected by marketing and how we think others are affected by marketing. I want to play you a clip for an ad that I recently came by.
因为他们认识到了这是一个问题。据我所知，现在住院医师不再有每天由各大制药公司赞助的免费午餐了。但重点是，医生们说他们没有受到这些礼物的影响，但其他医生受到了。所以这是一个完美的例子，说明利益冲突在自己身上无法识别，但在别人身上却能看到。偏见盲点也影响我们认为自己如何受营销影响，以及我们认为别人如何受营销影响。我想放一段我最近偶然看到的一则广告的片段。
GLH means great looking hair. Just spray GLH on and it instantly covers your ball spot, leaving you with great looking hair. GLH is not a paint or a cover-up. It's an amazing powder that clings to the tiniest hairs on your head. Order GLH now for only the other hair. So that was an ad for spray on hair. Now, I don't think I'm influenced by advertising,
GLH的意思是头发看起来很棒。只需在GLH上喷一喷，它就能瞬间覆盖你的秃斑，让你拥有看起来很棒的头发。GLH不是油漆或遮瑕膏。它是一种神奇的粉末，能依附在你头上最细的头发上。立即订购GLH，只需……另一款头发产品。所以那是喷雾生发剂的广告。现在，我不认为自己会受到广告的影响，
whether that's commercial advertising or political advertising, but I think other people are quite vulnerable to such persuasion. Yeah, there's a phenomenon called the third person effect whereby people think that persuasive attempts have more of an impact on other people than themselves. So they say, oh, commercials, political ads, those things, I'm immune to them. They don't influence me. Whereas people recognize it's a whole industry. It's influencing other people, but we see others as more susceptible to these influences
无论是商业广告还是政治广告，但我认为其他人非常容易受到这种说服的影响。是的，有一种现象叫做第三人称效应，即人们认为说服尝试对其他人的影响比对他们自己的影响更大。所以他们会说：“哦，商业广告、政治广告那些东西，我对它们免疫。它们不会影响我。”而人们承认这是一个庞大的行业。它在影响其他人，但我们认为其他人比我们自己更容易受到这些影响。
than ourselves. Yeah. How does this work in politics? When we evaluate our political opponents, how does this work in politics when we evaluate our political opponents? How does this bias sort of play out in our evaluations both of people on our side and people on the other side? Yeah, so that's a great question. And obviously, we've all been thinking about it a lot recently. So I think there's a lot of things that are going on.
是的。这在政治中是如何运作的？当我们评估我们的政治对手时，这在政治中是如何运作的？这种偏见在我们对自己阵营的人和对方阵营的人的评估中是如何体现的？是的，这是一个很好的问题。显然，我们最近都在思考这个问题。所以我认为有很多事情正在发生。
One is, what do I believe are the roots of my political opinions and political beliefs? And people will swear that the roots of their political beliefs are just an irrational analysis of the issue, right? So I take the positions I do because those are the correct positions. If you analyze the issues, if you analyze the state of the country, if you think about what's best for the nation, these are the correct positions. But they don't view that as being the root to the positions of those on the other side. So the other side is influenced by ideology, by self-interest, by prejudice, whatever it is.
其一是，我认为我的政治观点和政治信念的根源是什么？人们会发誓，他们政治信念的根源是对问题的理性分析，对吧？所以我持这样的立场，因为这些是正确的立场。如果你分析这些问题，如果你分析国家的现状，如果你考虑什么对国家最好，这些就是正确的立场。但他们不认为那是对方立场根源。所以对方是受到意识形态、自私自利、偏见或无论什么因素的影响。
I was thinking about this study that came out some time ago, and this was during the Obama presidency. Gas prices were really high, and people were asking, how much is the president responsible for high gas prices or low gas prices were really high and people were asking, you know, how much is the president responsible for high gas prices or low gas prices? And what was interesting is that the same group had asked the question to citizens during the presidency of George W. Bush when also gas prices were high. And what's fascinating and perhaps unsurprising is, of course, when gas prices are high and there's a Republican in the White House, most Republicans think the president has very little control over gas prices and therefore should not be blamed for it, and Democrats think the president has a lot of control of a gas price and should be blamed for it, and the tables are exactly turned when you have a Democrat in the White House, and so in both cases, people in very self-interested way see the data that they have and interpret it in a way that aligns with their
我想到了前段时间出炉的一项研究，那是在奥巴马总统任期内。当时油气价格非常高，人们在问，总统对油价高或油价低负有多大责任？而在乔治·W·布什总统任期内，当油气价格也很高时，同一群体也向市民提出过这个问题。有趣的是，也许并不令人意外，当然，当油价高涨而白宫里坐着一个共和党人时，大多数共和党人认为总统对油价的控制力很小，因此不应该因此受到指责；而民主党人则认为总统对油价有很大的控制力，应该受到指责。当白宫里换成民主党人时，情况就完全反过来了。所以在两情况下，人们都以一种极度自利的方式看待他们拥有的数据，并以符合其政治信仰的方式对其进行解读。
political beliefs. And of course, this is just one example. There must be hundreds of examples like this. That's right. And what's amazing is it's motivated reasoning. And both of those words are important, right? So it's motivated. I'm seeing things in a way that's consistent, right, with my motives, my prior beliefs.
当然，这只是一个例子。这样的例子一定有几百个。没错。令人惊奇的是，这是动机性推理。这两个词都很重要，对吧？所以它是受动机驱动的。我看到事物的方式与我的动机、我先前的信念相一致，对吧？
But it's also reasoning because they're not just saying, well, I'm just gonna believe whatever makes my side look better. Done, right? That would be just like pure motivation. There's reasoning going on. So people are actually stopping to think, okay, well, what are the factors that influence gas prices and who might be responsible for?
但它也是推理，因为他们不只是说：“好吧，我会相信任何能让我的阵营看起来更好的事情。就这样，对吧？”那将只是纯粹的动机。这里面有推理在起作用。所以人们实际上停下来思考，好吧，那么影响油价的因素是什么，谁可能对此负责？
And what's going on on the global political stage, you know, and so if you reason it out, these things are so complex that you can find reasons for almost anything, or at least for one of the two sides of the issue anyway. There is another curious dimension of the bias blind spot when we come up with positions on various issues where keenly aware of the nuances and subtleties of our opinions, but we don't extend the same respect to the views of our opponents. We very rarely say the views of the people who disagree with me are thoughtful and nuanced, right?
以及全球政治舞台上正在发生什么，你知道的，所以如果你推理一下，这些事情是如此复杂，以至于你几乎可以为任何事情找到理由，或者至少为该问题的两个方面之一找到理由。当我们对各种问题形成立场时，偏见盲点还有一个奇特的维度：我们敏锐地意识到我们意见中的细微差别和微妙之处，却不对对手的观点给予同样的尊重。我们极少说那些不同意我观点的人的看法是深思熟虑且充满细微差别的，对吧？
I think that's right. I think that there is more of a tendency to stereotype and caricatureize others and to recognize the nuance and complexity in our own views. And unfortunately, the political realm, I think, affords that makes that even more likely because people can't really express their own ambivalences and nuances, right? Because that's seen as sort of giving into the other side. So people do tend to portray themselves as sort of more clear and perhaps even more extreme in that respect as a result.
我认为是的。我认为人们更多地倾向于对他人进行刻板印象化和脸谱化，而认识到自己观点中的细微差别和复杂性。不幸的是，我认为政治领域使得这种倾向更有可能发生，因为人们无法真正表达他们自己的矛盾心理和细微差别，对吧？因为那被视为向对方妥协。因此，结果是人们确实倾向于把自己表现得更清晰，甚至在这方面更极端。
We've known for a long time that our evaluations of ourselves are very different than our evaluations of others. The Bible asks why we notice a speck of dust in our brother's eye, but ignore the beam sticking out of our own eye. When we come back, the psychological quirk that produces the radically different judgments we make of ourselves and others. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. All of us find it remarkably easy to identify bias among other people, especially our opponents. And all of us find it remarkably easy to identify bias among other people, especially our opponents. And all of us find it maddeningly difficult to spot biases in ourselves. Psychologist Emily Pronen has spent years studying this discrepancy in our perceptions, and she has found that much of the discrepancy comes down to the different yardsticks we use in judging ourselves and others. Emily, I'm not sure if you have watched
长期以来，我们都知道我们对自己的评估与对他人的评估截然不同。圣经问为什么我们能注意到弟兄眼中的刺，却看不见自己眼中的梁木。稍后回来，为您揭晓产生我们对自己与他人截然不同的判断的心理怪癖。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。我们所有人都发现，识别他人尤其是对手身上的偏见是极其容易的。我们所有人都发现，识别他人尤其是对手身上的偏见是极其容易的。而我们所有人都发现，要在自己身上发现偏见是令人发狂地困难。心理学家艾米·普罗宁花多年时间研究了我们认知中的这种差异，她发现这种差异很大程度上归结于我们在评判自己和他人时使用了不同的标尺。艾米，我不知道你有没有看过
the television show Veepe, but on the show there's a character named Jonah Ryan who decides to run for president. He's been advised that it's a bad look to be single, so he gets together with a woman who happens to be the daughter of a man his mom used to be married to. So she is his step sister. In an interview, Jonah prefers to think of his fiance as only his former step sister. So, what would you say to someone who might ask, how can they marry their step siblings? I'm not her brother, nor have I ever been her brother. Right. And the only time anyone could ever say that would be for that one year. I mean, it's exactly what Woody Allen did,
电视剧《副总统》，但剧中有一个叫乔纳·莱恩的角色决定竞选总统。有人建议他单身形象不好，于是他和一个碰巧是他母亲以前结过婚的男人的女儿的女人走到了一起。所以她是他的继妹。在一次采访中，乔纳更愿意认为他的未婚妻只是他前继妹。那么，对于可能会问“他们怎么能和自己的继兄弟姐妹结婚？”这样的人，你会对他说什么？我不是她的兄弟，也从来不是她的兄弟。对吧。唯一能说这话的时候也只有那一年。我的意思是，这完全就是伍迪·艾伦做过的事，
and nobody thinks he's weird. I mean, everybody just hates him because Ann's wasn't as good as a bug's life. Exactly. Yeah. So this is obviously a comedy show, Emily. But I'm wondering if you can just start by explaining when it comes to our judgments about the people,
而且没有人觉得他奇怪。我的意思是，每个人只是讨厌他，因为《安娜》没有《虫虫危机》那么好看。完全正确。是的。所以这显然是一部喜剧，艾米。但我想知道，你能不能先解释一下，当我们对他人作出判断时，
what is the yardstick that we use to evaluate that they are biased? The yardstick that we use is in one word behavior, their actions. The process is, it's almost like if you imagine a fork in the road and it just goes two different ways, there are just two different paths here. There's the path that we use for self-judgment and there's the path that we use for judging others. And in my view, the path that we use for judging others is we look at their actions. The path that we use for judging ourselves is we look inwards. And when I say look inwards,
我们用来评估他们是否存在偏见的标尺是什么？我们使用的标尺归根结底就是行为，即他们的行动。这个过程，几乎就像如果你想象道路分叉，它朝着两个不同的方向延伸，这里只是两条不同的路径。一条是我们用于自我判断的路径，另一条是我们用于判断他人的路径。在我看来，我们用来判断他人的路径是观察他们的行动。我们用来判断自己的路径是向内看。当我说是向内看时，
I mean we look to things like our thoughts, feelings, intentions, motives. So if the question is, did I marry my brother, you know, there's an action. There's a behavior. Right, I did it or I didn't. And that's how other people will judge it. But in judging myself, I might look much more to my motives and my intentions. Am I someone who would intend to marry their brother? No, that's weird. I would never intend to do that.
我的意思是，我们会关注诸如我们的思想、感受、意图、动机之类的事情。所以如果问题是，我有没有和我的兄弟结婚，你知道的，这是一个行动。这是一种行为。对，我做了或者我没做。这就是其他人会如何评判它。但在评判我自己时，我可能会更多地审视我的动机和意图。我是那种会意图和自己兄弟结婚的人吗？不，那太奇怪了。我绝不会有这种意图。
So I guess I didn't do it. And so, when we are interacting with other people, what we see is them. We see their actions, we see their expressions. But when we experience ourselves, we don't really see that. Instead, what we perceive is what's inside our heads. That's the information that we're flooded with. That's the information that we can't escape is our thoughts and feelings and intentions. So that's what we give so much way to.
所以我想我没有这样做。因此，当我们与其他人互动时，我们看到的是他们。我们看到他们的行动，我们看到他们的表情。但当我们体验自己时，我们并没有真正看到那些。相反，我们感知到的是我们脑海里的东西。那是充斥着我们的信息。那是我们无法逃避的信息，就是我们的思想、感觉和意图。所以这就是我们赋予如此大权重的东西。
So one of the things that jumps out at me from what you're saying Emily is that our introspection is our access to our own thoughts and feelings. These are with us all the time, so it's almost, we don't actually have to ask ourselves the question, how do I evaluate myself? We automatically go to looking inward to our thoughts and feelings. When it comes to our evaluations of other people, in some ways we don't have access to their thoughts and feelings. Those are hidden from us, and so we use what we have. And on the surface, this happens without any sort of conscious awareness that it's happening, right? So I don't realize I'm using a different yardstick to evaluate your behavior and a different yardstake to evaluate my. Right.
艾米，你所说的话中有一个让我感到突出的地方，那就是我们的内省是我们接触自己思想和感觉的途径。这些东西一直伴随着我们，所以几乎可以说，我们实际上不必问自己这个问题：“我该如何评估自己？”我们会自动转向内心，去审视我们的思想和感觉。而当我们评估其他人时，在某些方面我们无法接触到他们的思想和感觉。这些对我们是隐藏的，所以我们只能利用我们手头拥有的东西。从表面上看，这一切发生时没有任何有意识的觉察，对吧？所以我并没有意识到我在用一把标尺来评估你的行为，而用另一把标尺来评估我的行为。对。
I don't think that we really think about that explicitly. What we use in any judgment, psychologists can tell you, is the information that's salient. It's a psychologist like that term salient. The information that's available to us, whatever is fresh in our brains, is the information we use. And so it just so happens that for the self, the information that's fresh in our brains, all the time is that stuff that we perceive
我认为我们并没有明确地思考过这个问题。心理学家可以告诉你，我们在任何判断中使用的信息都是显著的信息。心理学家喜欢“显著”这个词。对我们而言可用的信息，无论大脑中多么新鲜，都是我们使用的信息。因此，碰巧的是，对于自我而言，一直以来在我们大脑中保持新鲜的信息，就是我们感知到存在于我们大脑中的东西，对吧？我们的思想和感觉，所有那些几乎恒常存在且我们几乎恒常觉察到的东西。这不仅仅是因为我们在评估自己和他人时使用了不同的标尺。这些标尺本身都是有缺陷的，而且是以不同方式存在缺陷。当我们通过内省来评估自己的行为时，我们想象自己可以看到我们所有的动机和意图，它们对我们是触手可及的。
to be in our brains, right? Our thoughts and feelings, all that stuff that's sort of just constantly there and that we're sort of constantly aware of. It's not just that we use different yardsticks in evaluating ourselves and others. Each of those yardsticks is flawed and flawed in a different way. When it comes to evaluating our own behavior through introspection, we imagine that we can see all our motives and intentions that they are accessible to us.
但事实并非如此。我们大脑中发生的一堆事情是我们并没有意识到的，对吧？我们没有意识到我们信念的来源。我们没有意识到，你知道的，如果我去冰淇淋店，比起香草味我选择了巧克力味，我知道那是我的选择。但我不知道为什么那是我的选择。那是在我无法接触的情况下大脑中正在发生的事情，但我们有时会忘记这一点。所以，我们认为我们可以向内看并找出一切，对吧？因此我们忘记了，例如，许多偏见和刻板印象都是在无意识中发生的。这意味着我无法通过内省来找到它们。
But it turns out that is not the case. There's a bunch of stuff that goes on in our brand that we're not aware of, right? We're not aware of the sources of our beliefs. We're not aware of, you know, if I go to the ice cream shop and I choose the chocolate ice cream over the vanilla, I am aware that that was my choice. But I'm not aware why that was my choice. That's happening in the brain without my having access to it, but we sometimes forget that. So, we think that we can look inwards and find out everything, right? So we forget, for example, that a lot of prejudice and stereotyping happens unconsciously. And that means I can't look inwards to find it.
我不大可能会怀有那些种族主义意图。这是现在人们经常谈论的事情。所以，并不是说仅仅因为我们头脑中拥有所有这些信息，就意味着它对做出我们需要做出的任何判断总是具有证明力的。嗯。我记得多年前曾与研究人员
I'm not necessarily going to have those racist intentions. That's something that people talk about a lot now. So it's not the case that just because we have access to all this information in our heads, that that means it's always going to be probative for making whatever judgment we need to make. Hmm. I remember speaking some years ago with the researcher
迈克尔·特斯勒交谈过，他针对共和党人和民主党人做了一个有趣的实验，当时正值国家辩论平价医疗法案或奥巴马医改之际。迈克尔·特斯勒的做法是，他向志愿者展示了平价医疗法案的细节，但他告诉其中一些人，该计划是由白人民主党总统比尔·克林顿提出的，而他告诉其他志愿者，该计划来自黑人民主党总统巴拉克·奥巴马。所以是相同的计划，相同的细节，都是由民主党总统提出的，只不过一个是白人总统，一个是黑人总统。他发现，双方
Michael Tesla, he ran an interesting experiment with Republicans and Democrats and this is back when the country was debating the Affordable Care Act or Obama care. And what Michael Tesla did is he presented volunteers with details of the Affordable Care Act, but he told some of them that the plan had been put forward by President Bill Clinton, a Democratic president who was white, and he told other volunteers the plan was from Barack Obama, a Democratic president who was black. So same plan, same details, both put forward by a Democratic president except that one was white and one president was black. And what he found was that both
自由派和保守派都潜移默化地受到了他们对总统种族身份的情感偏见的影响。当政策被包装为巴拉克·奥巴马提出时，白人种族自由派会更加支持该政策，而当被包装为比尔·克林顿提出时则不然；但白人种族保守派对该政策的支持度会降低。艾米，我觉得这正印证了你刚才所说的话。如果你问自由派和保守派：“你们是如何评估这项政策的？”他们会深入研究细节，并说：“这是我喜欢该政策的原因，或者这是我不喜欢该政策的原因。”没有人会说我对某个不同种族的人的亲近感或厌恶感
liberals and conservatives were subtly biased by their feelings about the racial identity of the president. White racial liberals become more supportive of a policy when it's framed as Barack Obama than when it's framed as Bill Clinton's, but white racial conservatives become less supportive of that policy. And Emily, I feel like this is speaking to what you just said. If you asked liberals and conservatives, how are you evaluating this policy? They will dive into the details and say, here's why I like the policy or here's why I don't like the policy. Neither will say my affinity or my aversion to someone from a different race
可能会塑造我对诸如平价医疗法案之类事情的看法。是的，我认为这完全正确听起来这是一项很棒的研究。这并不是说受试者在撒谎。他们说的是他们认为是事实的话。他们错误地假设，如果候选人的种族影响了他们的判断，他们是会知道的。现在，局外人可能会更快地注意到这种模式，因为他们不会
might be shaping my view on something like the Affordable Care Act. Yeah, I think that's exactly right, and that sounds like a great study. And it's not that the subjects were lying. They were saying what they believed to be the case. They assumed incorrectly that if the race of the candidate had impacted their judgment that they would know it. Now an outsider might be able to notice this pattern much more quickly because they wouldn't
依赖于他们的意图。他们只会看这个人在做什么。有时候，当我们观察行为时，事情可能会更容易看清楚。是的。几年前，艾米，你提出了一个关于为什么我们的内省不可靠的理论。你称之为内省错觉。什么是内省错觉？尽管我们可以接触到内省错觉？
be relying on their their intentions. They just be looking at what the person did. Sometimes when we look at behavior, things can be a little bit easier to see. Yeah. Some years ago, Emily, you came up with a theory of why our introspection are unreliable. You called it the introspection illusion. What is the introspection illusion? Although we have access to the introspection illusion?
尽管我们可以接触到我们的内省，这就是作为一个有意识的人的意义所在，你知道你的思想、你的感觉、你的动机和你的意图，它们一直都在你的脑海里，但我们对这能为我们做些什么有一些错觉。所以我们认为这……对这能为我们做些什么有一些错觉。所以我们认为这赋予了我们某种至高无上的自我认知，某种凭借我们可以了解关于自己的各种事情的能力，因为我们可以接触到这些信息。我们还认为，我们的行为远不如了解我们脑海里的东西那么重要。就我们自己而言，我们的意图是如此重要，以至于必须要了解。
Although we have access to our introspection, this is sort of what it means to be a conscious person as you Know your thoughts and your feelings and your motives and your intentions and they're there all the time in your head we have some illusions about what that Can do for us. So we think that that illusions about what that can do for us. So we think that that gives us sort of supreme self-knowledge, sort of that we can know all sorts of things about ourselves because we have access to this information. We also think that our behavior is less important than knowing what's inside of our heads. In the case of ourselves, it's our intentions that are so important to know.
就我们自己而言，我们的意图是如此重要，以至于必须要了解。你知道，几年前我曾与哈佛大学的心理学家马扎林·班纳吉交谈过，她对我说了一件非常有趣的事。她说：“你知道的，如果你的心脏有问题，你可能会去找心脏病专家做检查。心脏病专家说，你的心脏出了什么问题。你倾向于相信她，因为你认为心脏病专家比你更了解你的心脏。你不会对心脏病专家说：‘这是我的心脏，因此我对我的心脏一定最具有专家资格，因为它属于我。’”但马扎林·班纳吉说，同样的事情
in the case of ourselves, it's our intentions that are so important to know. You know, I was speaking some years ago with Mausoleum Bananjee, the psychologist at Harvard, and she said something really interesting to me. She said, you know, if you have a problem with your heart, you might go to a cardiologist to get it checked out. And the cardiologist says, here's what's wrong with your heart. You're inclined to believe her because you think the cardiologist knows more than you do about your heart. You don't tell the cardiologist, it's my heart. Therefore, I must be the expert on my heart because it belongs to me. But my serenin Benadji was saying the same thing
并没有发生在我们的头脑中。当专家走出来说“让我向你解释你的大脑是如何运作的”时，这是很难接受的，因为在某种程度上，我们所有人都觉得自己是自身大脑的专家。我认为这在部分上与你所说的内省错觉有关。感觉我们的内心世界是如此丰富，我们在其中花费了如此多的时间，以至于在某些方面我们觉得我们理解它们是如何运作的。
doesn't happen with our minds. It's very hard when an expert comes along and says, let me explain to you how your mind works because at some level, all of us feel like we are experts in our own minds. And that's partly, I think, connected to what you're calling the introspection illusion. It feels like our mental worlds are so rich and we spend so much time in them that it feels in some ways we understand how they work.
而在某些方面，这可能是一种错觉。没错。而且看，这根植于我们自己领域的历史中。在心理学发展的早期，当人们想要了解思维时，他们会让人们进入实验室，坐在房间里进行内省。他们说：“这就是我们将要了解思维工作原理的方式。”然后，你知道的，出现了一次巨大的强烈反弹。行为主义者随之出现，他们说：“这是无稽之谈。我们无法通过要求人们向我们汇报他们脑海中发生的事情来了解思维的工作原理。”所以他们说：
And in some ways, that could be an illusion. That's right. And look, it's embedded in the history of our own field. In the very early days of psychology, when people wanted to understand the mind, they had people come into the laboratory, sit in a room, and introspect. And they said, this is how we're going to learn how the mind works. And then, you know, there was a huge backlash. The behaviorists came along and they said, this is nonsense. We cannot learn about how the mind works by asking people to report to us what's going on in their mind. So they said,
我们要抛弃所有这些。我们将只关注行为，因为那是可观察的。然后，你知道的，我们迎来了认知心理学的第三次浪潮，我们意识到我们可以使用客观策略和严格的方法来研究思维，而不依赖于人们告诉我们他们自己的思维中正在发生什么。我想这部分也基于这样一种想法：如果发生在我们头脑中的一切实际上都可以通过有意识的内省来获取，
we're getting rid of all of that. So we're just going to focus on behavior because that is observable. And then, you know, we had sort of a third wave of cognitive psychology where we realized that there were objective strategies and paracol methods that we could use to study the mind that did not rely on people telling us what was going on in their own minds. And I think part of this also rests on the idea that if everything that happens in our mind was actually accessible to conscious introspection,
如果我们非常诚实且非常勤奋，我们或许事实上能够审视我们的内心并看到一切。但事实上，如果我们思维的大部分实际上是在我们有意识的觉察之外运作的，你知道的，我们的思维正在做的事情根本无法通过内省为我们所获取。对，完全正确。
we might in fact, if we were very honest and very diligent, be able to look inside our minds and see everything. But in fact, if much of our minds actually are operating outside of our conscious awareness, you know, what our minds are doing is simply not accessible to us through introspection. Right, exactly.
我们之前交谈时你提到了光环效应。关于光环效应的著名实验来自蒂姆·威尔逊和理查德·尼斯比特在1977年的研究。他们让人们观看一段视频，视频中一个带有“所谓外国口音”的教授在说话，我不知道他是什么口音。然后他们让实验中的受试者评估这位教授。
You brought up the halo effect when we were talking earlier. And the famous experiment on the halo effect comes from Tim Wilson and Richard Nisbit back in 1977. And they had people watch a video in which a professor with a quote unquote foreign accent, I'm not sure what his accent was talking. And then they asked subjects in the experiment to evaluate this professor.
其中一半的受试者看到视频中的教授表现得冷漠、不太讨人喜欢。另一半受试者看到他表现得热情、非常讨人喜欢。之后，他们询问受试者对他的看法，在教授不讨人喜欢的组别中，人们被问及口音时说他们不喜欢他的口音。在讨人喜欢的组别中，他们确实喜欢他的口音。所以发生的事情是，由实验者操纵的教授讨人喜欢与否，影响了人们认为该口音有多讨人喜欢。
And half of the subjects had seen the professor in the video acting cold, not very likable. And the other half of subjects had seen him acting warm, very likable. And afterwards, they asked the subjects what they thought of him and what people said in the unlikable professor condition was that they didn't like his accent when they were asked about his accent. In the likable condition they did like his accent. So what happened was the likability of the professor, which was manipulated by the experimenters, influenced how much people thought the accent was likable.
但他们根本没有意识到这一点。他们无法接触到是什么影响了他们对口音的感知。现在，作为实验者，我们知道了，对吧？因为我们看到那些遇到不讨人喜欢教授的人认为那是糟糕的口音，而那些遇到讨人喜欢教授的人认为那是好口音。所以实验者可以这样说：“天哪，我们知道他们是怎么得出这个结论的。”但受试者并不知道，受试者只是向内看并说：“这纯粹是无稽之谈，我怎么会根据别人有多好来评估某人的口音，这毫无道理。”他们完全没有意识到自己曾这样做过，它是无意识发生的，而他们予以否认。
But they didn't realize that this had happened at all. They had no access to what had influenced their perception of the accent. Now, we knew as experimenters, right? Because we saw those who got the unlikable professor thought it was a bad accent, and those who got the likable professor thought it was a good accent. So the experimenters could say, gee, we know how they came to this conclusion. But the subject didn't know that the subject just looked inwards and said that's a bunch of who we why would I evaluate someone's accent have likeable their accent is based on how
你可以看到同样的现象在更大规模上在政治中上演，例如，我们刚刚经历了一场总统大选。当然，90%的共和党人投票给了共和党候选人，90%或更高的民主党人可能投票给了民主党候选人。但如果你问其中任何一个人：“你为什么要投票给这个候选人？”他们会给你一堆非常微妙的理由，说明为什么他们认为这个候选人比另一个候选人更好。而一个来自火星的中立观察者可能会说：“好吧，人们其实只是在投票给他们所属政党的候选人。”
nice they were that makes no sense they had no awareness of having done that it occurred unconsciously and they denied it and you can see the same thing played on a much larger scale when it comes to politics for example we've you know just been through a presidential election. And of course, 90% of Republicans voted for the Republican candidate, 90% of Democrats, or higher may have voted for the Democratic candidate. But if you ask any one of those people, why did you vote for the candidate? They will give you a whole bunch of reasons that are very nuanced about why they thought this candidate was better than the other candidate. Whereas somebody who is the neutral observer from Mars might come along and say, well, people are just simply voting for whoever their party candidate is.
候选人是谁其实并没有什么区别。在某些方面，我觉得这是你刚才所描述内容的延伸。我们做某事可能有一个潜在原因，但一旦我们做了，当某人在我们的行动结束后寻找解释时，在某种程度上是为了证明我们当初是如何得出这些行动的合理性。没错。我们认为自己是理性的，我们是基于理性决策和理性分析来选择候选人的，但实际上我们所做的是在进行合理化解释。实际上，确实有其他因素决定了我们更倾向于哪位候选人，然后在事后，我们通过提出看似理性的理由来使之合理化。
It doesn't really make a difference who that candidate is. And in some ways, I feel like that's an extension of what you were just describing. There might be an underlying reason we are doing something, but once we do it, when somebody is searching for explanations after our actions are over, in some ways to justify how it is, we arrived at those actions in the first place. That's right. We think we're being rational that we're choosing the candidate based on rational decision-making and rational analysis, but really what we're doing is we're rationalizing. Really actually there's other factors that have determined which candidate we
感觉我们对自我和他人的评估是由这双重力量塑造的。一方面，我们赋予自身的内省以比我们可能应该获得的更大的权重。但另一方面，我们却打了折扣去忽视其他人的内省。
prefer, and then after the fact we rationalize it by coming up with what seem like rational reasons. And it feels like our evaluations of ourselves and others is shaped by these dual forces. On the one hand, we ascribe greater way to our own introspection than maybe we should. But on the other, we discount the introspection of other people.
换句话说，我不认为我的政治对手真的非常仔细地思考过他们是如何选择行动方针的。我多少可以把他们打发为容易被引导、盲从的羊群。尽管我们过高估计了我们自己的内省，但我们却低估了其他人的内在思维过程。是的。我们甚至做过这样的实验：我们说，看吧，也许人们低估他人思维过程的原因只是他们无法接触到这些，对吧？我们甚至做过这样的实验：我们说，看吧，也许人们低估他人思维过程的原因只是他们无法接触到这些，对吧？
So in other words, I don't think that my political opponents have actually thought very carefully about how they've chosen their course of action. I sort of can dismiss them as being easily led as being sheep. Even as we overvalue our own introspection, we undervalue the internal thought processes of other people. Yes. And we've even done experiments where we say, look, maybe the reason why people undervalue others thought processes is that they just don't have access to them, right? And we've even done experiments where we say, look, maybe the reason why people undervalued others thought processes is that they just don't have access to them, right? You know, you have such rich access to what's going on in your head. So we will give people an entire think-aloud protocol, meaning that before the subject made
你知道，你对脑海中正在发生的事情有着如此丰富的触及渠道。所以我们会让人们进行完整的“大声思考”协议，这意味着在受试者做出决定之前，他们把自己的想法大声说进录音机里。他们倾倒出自己所有的想法，然后把这些给受试者听。而他们仍然置之不理。所以我们实际上做了一项关于政治信念的研究。这是与乔纳·伯杰和萨拉·马卢基合作完成的。我们捏造了各种加利福尼亚州的提案。其中一个是关于增加洛杉矶港口最大货物尺寸的。然后我们告诉人们他们各自政党对这些提案的立场。所以民主党支持这个，或者共和党支持这个。我们让他们选择自己的立场，也就是投票。我们问他们是否受到了他们政党立场的影响？受试者说：
their decision, they thought allowed into a tape recorder. They just dumped all their thoughts and will give that to the subject to hear. And they still disregard it. So we actually did a study with political beliefs. And this was with Jonah Berger and Sarah Maluki. We made up various California propositions. One was about increasing the maximum cargo size at the port of Los Angeles. When then we told people their parties position on them. So the Democrats support this or their Republicans support this. And we asked them to choose their position to vote essentially. And we asked them were they influenced by their parties position? And subjects said
不，我没有受到影响。我只是评估了这个议题。在他们说出自己将采取什么立场之前，我们让他们列出他们所有的想法。他们倾倒了他们对这个议题的所有想法。然后我们把这些交给另一个人去评估。而另一个人根本不在乎所有这些。所以人们说：“我是根据自己的想法走的，我评估了这个议题。”但局外人却说：“哦天哪，我不需要看所有这些想法。那不相关。你是个民主党人。你选择了民主党人的立场。完事。”
no, I wasn't influenced by that. I just evaluated the issue. Before they said what position they would take, we had them list all their thoughts. They dumped out all of their thoughts on the issue. And then we gave that to another person to also evaluate. And the other person didn't care about any of that. So people said, I went with my thoughts, I evaluated the issue. But the outsider said, oh gee, I don't need to see all those thoughts. That's not relevant. You're a Democrat. You want with the Democratic position. Done.
简单。与你的研究相关的另一个观点是关于我们如何过高估计脑海中发生的事情、而较少关注其他人脑海中发生的事情，这种现象叫做朴素实在论。你能谈谈那是什么以及它与你的工作有何关联吗？我们今天讨论的大部分内容，我认为确实根植于我们大脑的基本功能。这正是我们的设计方式，对吧？
Simple. One of the other ideas that's connected to your work on how we overvalue the things happening in our minds and pay less attention to the things happening in other people's minds is a phenomenon called naive realism. Can you talk about what that is and how it connects to your work? So much of what we're talking about today, I think, is really rooted in the basic functioning of our brains. It's just how we are designed, right?
例如，我们长着眼睛，这引导我们去看别人的行为，但眼睛是不会向内看的。而且正是这种基本的大脑结构决定了如此多的事情，而这确实与此有关。它与这样一种观点有关：存在一些基本且不可逃避的信念。其中之一就是，我认为我看到的世界就是客观现实中的世界。
So for example, we have eyes in our head, and those lead us to see other people's behaviors, but the eyes don't look inwards. And there's just sort of basic brain architecture that determines so much, and I've really some has to do with this. It has to do with the idea that there are some basic and inescapable beliefs. And one is that I believe that I see the world as it is in objective reality.
因此，我认为其他人看到的世界会和我一样。当其他人没有看到时，我必须做出解释。我倾向于解释的方式要么是说：“他们不明白，我需要教育他们”；要么退而求其次说：“他们有什么毛病，要么他们很笨，要么他们有偏见。”你可以在日常互动中看到朴素实在论在起作用，以喜剧演员乔治·卡林观察到的事情为例。你有没有注意到当你开车时，任何开得比你慢的人都是白痴？
And as a result, I think that others will see the world the same as I do. And that when others don't, I have to explain it. And the way that I tend to explain it is either by saying, they don't understand, I need to educate them or failing that saying There's something wrong with them either they're stupid or they're biased You can see naive realism at work in everyday interactions take for example something that the comedian George Carlin observed Have you ever noticed when you're driving that anyone who's driving slower than you is an idiot?
因此，我认为其他人会以和我相同的方式看待世界。而当其他人并非如此时，我便不得不去解释。我倾向于采用的解释方式要么是说他们不理解，我需要去教育他们；如果行不通，就说他们有问题，要么是他们蠢，要么是他们有偏见。你可以在日常互动中看到朴素实在论发挥作用，例如喜剧演员乔治·卡林观察到的现象：你有没有注意到，当你开车时，任何开得比你慢的人都是个白痴？
And anyone driving faster than you is a maniac! Yes, I love that quote. It reminds me of one time I was in the kitchen preparing some food and my seven-year-old was in the playroom with my father, his ground father, and they were looking at different cars in a magazine and my son kept preferring the big SUVs, you know, and my father preferred the little boxer type cars and at some point my father said to him, I know what's a matter of taste, but your taste is stupid. taste is stupid. That's a great story. That's a wonderful story. And I feel it speaks to something that I think is really important. Parents and teachers are constantly trying to teach this lesson. Don't jump to conclusions, slow down, don't assume you know what's happening
任何开得比你快的人都是疯子！是的，我很喜欢那句话。这让我想起有一次我在厨房准备食物，我七岁的儿子和我的父亲——他的爷爷——在游戏室里，他们看着杂志上的不同汽车，我儿子一直更喜欢大型SUV，你知道的，而我父亲更喜欢那种小型拳击手类型的车，在某个时候我父亲对他说，我知道这是个口味问题，但你的口味太蠢了。口味太蠢了。真是个好故事。真是个精彩的故事。我觉得这说明了一件我认为非常重要的事情。父母和老师经常试图教导这个道理。不要妄下结论，慢下来，不要自以为你知道发生了什么
in someone else's head. And yet it's so hard to remember to practice these lessons, right? I mean, as a parent and as a teacher yourself, do you sometimes go, you know, I'm doing the exact same thing I tell my kids not to do? Yes, because these things are so automatic and so natural. These are tendencies that we have to override in ourselves. We can't eliminate them, right? Because so the tendency to think you see the world as it is, an objective reality. And therefore, if you like the race car better than the SUV, that it truly is better.
在别人的脑海里。然而，要记住实践这些教训是多么困难，对吧？我的意思是，作为一个父母，你自己也是个老师，你有时会想，你知道吗，我正在做和我告诉我的孩子不要做的事情一模一样的事情？是的，因为这些事情太自动、太自然了。这些是我们必须在自己身上克服的倾向。我们无法消除它们，对吧？因为认为自己所看到的客观现实就是世界的本来面目这种倾向。因此，如果你比SUV更喜欢赛车，它就真的是最好的。
That tendency is sort of an escapeable. And when children do it, they don't realize even that there's a distinction when they're young between their perception as reality. As we get older, we come to recognize, right, oh wait a second, that's a matter of taste, right? Like at some level, we come to realize, oh no, no, there's different perspectives and it's some artists. But that initial belief that we have in from childhood that my perception as reality doesn't really go away. And so it does actually feel that the cart we prefer is the better one. There are lots of implications that stem from what Emily calls this basic architecture of
这种倾向是某种无法逃避的东西。当孩子们这样做时，他们甚至没有意识到在他们小的时候，他们的感知和现实之间有什么区别。随着我们年龄的增长，我们开始认识到，对吧，哦，等一下，这是一个口味问题，对吧？就像在某种程度上，我们开始意识到，哦，不，不，有不同的视角，而且有些艺术家。但是我们从小就有的那种对“我的感知就是现实”的最初信念并没有真正消失。因此，事实上，我们更喜欢的赛车确实感觉就是更好的一辆。艾米丽所说的这种由大脑基本架构延伸出来的含义有很多。
the brain. Here is one that should be familiar to all of us. If I'm late for a meeting, my mind is chock full with all the reasons I'm late. Traffic was terrible, I had a childcare crisis, and so on. But if someone else is late for a meeting, I don't have access to all that stuff happening inside their heads. It's easy for me to think of them as just being irresponsible or careless. Psychologists call this the fundamental attribution error.
这里有一个我们所有人都应该熟悉的。如果我开会迟到了，我的脑子里塞满了迟到的各种原因。交通糟糕透顶，我遇到了育儿危机，诸如此类。但如果别人开会迟到了，我就无法了解他们脑子里发生的所有事情。我很容易认为他们只是不负责任或粗心大意。心理学家称之为基本归因谬误。
Another implication of this work has to do with the phenomenon of magical thinking. Magical thinking involves the idea that our thoughts could somehow influence the world around us. So, for example, if I think ill thoughts about you, can that give you a headache? Or if I think positive thoughts about my favorite player on the team, well that helped them score a goal. And we found that in fact this was the case. So for example, we had people think evil thoughts about someone else in the experiment.
这项工作的另一个含义与思维魔法现象有关。思维魔法包含这样一种想法：我们的想法可以以某种方式影响我们周围的世界。所以，例如，如果我对你有不好的想法，这会让你头痛吗？或者，如果我对队里最喜欢的球员抱有积极的想法，那能帮他们进球吗？我们发现事实的确如此。例如，我们让实验中的人对其他人产生邪恶的想法。
We said we're interested in whether you could place a hex on the person and then they stuck pins in a voodoo doll. And then the other person reported a headache because they worked for us and we told them to. Right. And what happened was if you were told to think ill about the other person before putting those pins in, you were told, just take a minute and think of something terrible. Just think of the worst thing you can happening to this person. And then you stuck the pins in the doll. Then you felt like you caused the headache and you felt bad. And we found the same thing with basketball before a big university basketball game. We had people think about the different players and think about how each one of them could contribute
我们说我们有兴趣了解你是否能对这个人下咒，然后他们在伏都娃娃上扎针。然后另一个人报告说头痛，因为他们为我们工作，我们就是这么告诉他们的。对。发生的事情是，如果在把那些针扎进去之前，你被告知要想那个其他人的坏话，你被告知，只需花一分钟时间想一些糟糕的事情。只想你能想到的发生在这个人身上的最糟糕的事情。然后你把针扎进娃娃里。然后你觉得自己导致了头痛，你感到很糟糕。我们在大学篮球大战前夕在篮球运动中也发现了同样的情况。我们让人们考虑不同的球员，思考他们每个人如何能够做出贡献
to the game and how would they help their team score well. And then we asked them after the game how much impact they felt that their thoughts had on the score of the game. So they thought that they'd impacted the game when they had thought about the players doing well, and the way that it's related is it again involves putting way too much weight on what's going on inside our heads. Because we're basically saying that what's going on inside my head could give someone else a headache, or what's going on inside my head when I sit in the stands of a basketball game could influence the player's score. How many baskets they shot.
为了比赛，他们将如何帮助他们的球队取得好成绩。然后在比赛结束后，我们询问他们觉得自己的想法对比赛分数有多大影响。所以当他们想到球员表现很好时，他们认为他们对比赛产生了影响，其关联的方式是它再次涉及对我们脑海中发生的事情给予了过多的权重。因为我们基本上是在说，我脑子里发生的事情可能会让别人头痛，或者当我坐在篮球比赛的看台上时，我脑子里发生的事情可能会影响球员的得分。他们投了多少个篮。
I mean, if it's a critical moment in the game, I would feel terrible getting up to leave the room and get some popcorn. I feel like, I can't let my team down. How could I do that to them? The introspection illusion, the biased blind spot, and naive realism, have profound consequences in our daily lives.
我的意思是，如果这是比赛的关键时刻，我离开房间去拿爆米花会觉得糟糕透顶。我觉得，我不能让我的球队失望。我怎么能对他们做出这种事呢？内省错觉、偏见盲点和朴素现实主义，对我们的日常生活有着深远的影响。
They do more than shape our thinking in basketball games. They shape life and death decisions and choices to go to war. That's when we come back. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Psychologist Emily Pronen has found we judge ourselves very differently from the way we judge others. This is because we use different yardsticks while doing those two things. We evaluate others based on their behavior, but we evaluate our own actions using introspection, and it turns out introspection is not a useful guide to understanding our own minds. Emily, I want to talk about some of the implications of this work and the ways in which it plays
它们对我们的影响不仅仅是塑造我们在篮球比赛中的思维。它们塑造了生死抉择和参战的选择。我们马上回来。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。心理学家艾米丽·普罗嫩发现，我们对自己和他人的判断截然不同。这是因为我们在做这两件事时使用了不同的标尺。我们根据别人的行为来评价他们，但我们用内省来评价自己的行为，事实证明，内省并不是理解我们自身心灵的有用指南。艾米丽，我想谈谈这项工作的一些影响以及它在现实世界中体现出来的方方面面。
out in the real world. And I want to start with an example of something that can seem trivial, but that produces widespread conflict across the United States. I'm going to let Wuppie Goldberg explain. A survey found that one of the most common arguments this time of year in households across America is what temperature to put thermostat at? Everybody relates.
我想从一个看起来微不足道，但在美国各地引发广泛冲突的例子开始。我请乌比·戈德堡来解释一下。一项调查发现，每年这个时候美国各地家庭中最常见的争论之一是把恒温器调到什么温度？每个人都能感同身受。
Oh my gosh. I mean, uh-huh. Yeah. that's right. Everybody, we race. Oh my gosh. We are like, uh-huh. Yeah. There's a lot of stuff we should be talking about, because it's on the list, but this interests me. Because I feel like everybody deals with this, if you wish. So Emily, I want to draw attention to the fact that this is a topic that you bring up.
哦，天哪。我的意思是，嗯哼。是的。那是对的。每个人，我们比赛。哦，天哪。我们就像，嗯哼。是的。有很多事情我们应该讨论，因为它在名单上，但这引起了我的兴趣。因为我觉得每个人都在处理这个问题，如果你愿意的话。所以艾米丽，我想提请大家注意，这是你提出的一个话题。
Almost everyone has an opinion about it and the opinion is often heated. Tell me how it connects to the conversation we're having about how we think about our minds, other people's minds, and the judgments we arrive at. I just love the idea of the thermostat wars. It's so real. I think it goes back to that quote. I know it's a matter of taste, but your taste is stupid. Because essentially, if I think that the temperature should be set to 73 and you think it should be set to 68, I do realize that this is a matter of taste, right? That there's no right answer here.
几乎每个人对此都有看法，而且这种看法往往很激烈。告诉我，这与我们正在进行的关于我们如何思考我们的思想、别人的思想以及我们得出的判断的对话有何联系？我非常喜欢恒温器之战这个概念。它是如此真实。我想这可以追溯到那句话。我知道这是个口味问题，但你的口味太蠢了。因为本质上，如果我认为温度应该设定在73度，而你认为应该设定在68度，我确实意识到这是一个口味问题，对吧？这里没有正确答案。
But at another level, I actually think that the temperature that I wanted to be at is the correct one. And it's like that George Carlin quote, right? If you want it to be hotter than me, you're a little soft and ridiculous, and you're wasting a lot of energy. If you want it to be colder than me, you've got to be kidding.
但在另一个层面上，我其实认为我想要的温度才是正确的。就像乔治·卡林的那句话一样，对吧？如果你想比我更热，你有点娇气和荒唐，而且你在浪费大量的能量。如果你想比我更冷，你一定是在开玩笑。
Do you really need to be that aesthetic and suffer like that? We can turn up the heat a little bit more, right? So we think in some matter of taste, but we also think we're right. And I've done some research with Nate Sheik and Shane Blackman where we show this with paintings. People say, oh, paintings, that's a matter of taste. Until someone disagrees with them about which are the nice paintings and which are the
你真的需要那么苦行并遭受那样的痛苦吗？我们可以把暖气开得再高一点，对吧？所以我们认为有些事是口味问题，但我们也认为自己是对的。我和内特·希克以及肖恩·布莱克曼做了一些研究，我们用画作证明了这一点。人们说，哦，画作，那是口味问题。直到有人不同意他们关于哪些是好看的画，哪些是
bad paintings. And then all of a sudden, they say that that person is wrong. Tell me a little bit more about the art study. I'm fascinated by the examples that you used and what you found. So Shane collected some images of paintings from art history books. So these were paintings by famous artists and they were in major museums and they were arranged from abstract to portraits and we would show them to a subject and ask them to rate which ones they thought were truly great and which ones they thought were overrated and
坏画的看法。然后突然之间，他们说那个人错了。跟我多讲讲这个艺术研究。我对你使用的例子以及你的发现着迷。因此，肖恩从艺术史书中收集了一些画作的图像。所以这些是著名艺术家的画作，它们在各大博物馆展出，从抽象派到肖像画应有尽有，我们会把它们展示给受试者，让他们评判哪些是他们认为真正伟大的，哪些是他们认为被高估的
then we showed them cover story for this of another subject who had supposedly done the same task but that subject totally disagreed with them so if I thought it was great they thought it was overrated and vice versa and then they had to evaluate this other person. And although they said that opinions on art were a matter of taste, when they saw this person who disagreed with them, they actually thought that the person was wrong and had been influenced by improper influences, because otherwise they surely would have agreed with oneself. And we've done studies with chefs, Kobe Sassarski, my student, to study with chefs and chefs
然后我们向他们展示了另一个据称完成了相同任务的受试者的掩护故事，但那个受试者完全不同意他们的看法——所以如果我认为它很棒，他们就会认为它被高估了，反之亦然——然后他们必须评估这个人。尽管他们说对艺术的观点是个口味问题，但当他们看到这个不同意他们观点的人时，他们实际上认为这个人错了，并且受到了不当影响的影响，因为否则他们肯定会同意自己的观点。我们和厨师们一起做过研究，我的学生科比·萨萨斯基和厨师们一起做研究，厨师们
showed this exact phenomenon, right? There's an objectively correct amount that the meat should be cooked, that the pasta should be cooked, you know how much it should be salted, and those who do it the other way are wrong. I want to point to something that you said earlier that I think might connect with this, which is in some ways when we think about our own subjective conclusions, when we think about a painting or how long pasta should be cooked, we're actually not thinking of this as being subjective. It genuinely feels as if we have a master, a whole bunch of objective data and arrived at this conclusion that in some ways feels objective. So, you know, we might say, yes, my taste in art and music is subjective, but it actually feels like it's not, that it's actually objective. And part of it is that when things come to us through the senses,
表现出了这种确切的现象，对吧？肉应该煮到多少、意大利面应该煮到多少、你知道应该加多少盐，这些都有一个客观正确的量，而用其他方法做的人都是错的。我想指出你之前说过的一句话，我认为这可能与此有关，也就是说，在某些情况下，当我们思考我们自己的主观结论时，当我们思考一幅画或意大利面应该煮多久时，我们其实并不认为这是主观的。它确实感觉就像我们掌握了大量的客观数据，并得出了这个在某种程度上感觉很客观的结论。所以，你知道，我们可能会说，是的，我对艺术和音乐的品味是主观的，但它实际上感觉并不主观，而是客观的。部分原因在于，当事物通过感官传达到我们这里时，
it comes so quickly that we do not feel the operation of the mind being involved. I know if I preferred to get the chocolate ice cream to the minship ice cream, but if you ask me why, I simply don't have access to that. And so it doesn't feel like there's been all these intervening processes that could have biased it. So when the piece of food hits my mouth, and I think that it has too much salt, I don't have access to any brain processes that are influencing that judgment. It's just, yeah, that's too salty. And it's an immediate feeling. And because it is so immediate, it's hard to imagine that it could have been biased by anything. I'm wondering if this is connected in some way, Assembly, to other work that you have
它来得如此之快，以至于我们感觉不到大脑运作的参与。我知道我是否更喜欢巧克力冰淇淋而不是薄荷冰淇淋，但如果你问我为什么，我根本无法知道。所以感觉好像没有所有这些可能使其产生偏差的干预过程。因此，当食物进入我的嘴里，我认为它盐放得太多时，我无法接触到任何影响这种判断的大脑过程。这只是，是的，太咸了。这是一种即时的感觉。正因为它如此即时，所以很难想象它会被任何东西所左右。我想知道这是否在某种程度上与你做过的其他研究有关，
done that looks at how we perform during interviews, but also how we judge other people during interviews. So we all think that we can sit before someone for half an hour, talk to them, and get a pretty good sense of whether this person is a good fit for a job. But if someone were to come along and say, oh, we can talk to you for half an hour, and figure out if you are a good fit for the job,
艾米丽，这些研究着眼于我们在面试中的表现，以及我们在面试中如何判断他人。所以我们都认为我们可以和某人坐在一起半个小时，跟他们谈谈，就能很好地了解这个人是否适合这份工作。但是如果有人走过来对我们说，哦，我们可以和你谈半个小时，弄清楚你是否适合这份工作，
we say that's clearly inadequate, because I'm so much more complex than anything that can be ascertained in 30 minutes. Right. So, there's a term, the interview illusion, which I did not coin. And it was about this idea that it's an illusion that you can tell so much from an interview. If I want to know whether you're going to be a good brick layer, it's probably a lot more valuable to me to watch you lay bricks and for me to ask your five prior bosses,
我们会说这显然是不够的，因为我比任何能在30分钟内确定下来的东西都要复杂得多。没错。所以，有一个术语叫“面试错觉”，这不是我发明的。它是关于这样一种想法：你可以从一次面试中看出那么多东西，这是一种幻觉。如果我想知道你是否会成为一个好的泥瓦匠，让我看着你砌砖，并让我去问你之前的五个老板，
how well you lay bricks, then for me to sit down and interview you about how good a Biblical area you are. And yet, people love interviews. And even psychologists, we do job interviews. Why do we do that? We could just ask the people who've worked with the person. We could ask their advisors to write letters, and we could read their work, but we do interviews as well.
你砌砖砌得有多好，可能比我坐下来面试你你是一个多好的泥瓦匠更有价值。然而，人们热爱面试。甚至心理学家，我们也会进行工作面试。我们为什么要这样做？我们本可以去问那些和这个人共事过的人。我们可以请他们的导师写推荐信，我们可以阅读他们的作品，但我们也会进行面试。
And we put a lot of weight on them. And the work that I did, we actually had people come into the laboratory and pairs. These were students who never met each other and they talked to each other for a half an hour. And we found that at the end of the half an hour, they felt like they'd really come to know the other person. But that the other person had not really come to know them.
而且我们对它们寄予厚望。在我所做的研究中，我们实际上让人们成对地进入实验室。这些是从未见过彼此的学生，他们互相交谈了半个小时。我们发现，在半个小时结束时，他们觉得他们真的开始了解对方了。但另一个人并没有真正了解他们。
So you could only get a small understanding and a small glimpse of who I am from that conversation, but I've got the whole you. And part of that has to do with the fact that I know all the stuff about me that you didn't find out from that conversation. I'm aware of all the stuff I didn't say. All the stuff I said that maybe was misleading about who I really am. I've got all that, but I don't have all that about you. I've got all that, but I don't have all that about you. You can see how these biases might play out in the context, not just of interpersonal conflict, but geopolitical conflict.
所以你只能从那次对话中对我是谁有一个小的理解和一瞥，但我已经掌握了完整的你。部分原因在于，我知道所有关于我自己的事情，而你并没有从那次对话中发现。我知道所有我没有说的事情。所有我说的可能对我是谁产生误导的事情。我掌握了所有这些，但我并没有掌握所有关于你的这些。我掌握了所有这些，但我并没有掌握所有关于你的这些。你可以看到这些偏见是如何在不仅是人际冲突，而且是地缘政治冲突的背景下发挥作用的。
If you think you see the world accurately and I don't, if you try to set me straight and find you can't change my views, what are you to conclude? The simplest explanation is that I can't be trusted. There's no point trying to understand me, or reason with me, or negotiate with me, because I must be either stupid or evil. It's not just people's actions that influence how we wanna respond to them.
如果你认为你看世界很准确而我没有，如果你试图纠正我却发现你无法改变我的观点，你会得出什么结论？最简单的解释是我不可信。试图理解我、和我讲道理或与我谈判是没有意义的，因为我一定是个笨蛋或是个恶棍。不仅仅是人们的行为影响了我们对他们的回应方式，
It's also our beliefs about what those actions stem from, and if we believe that individuals are biased, that their mental processes are biased, then we don't believe that it makes sense to try to reason with them. Is there any evidence that teaching people about the ways in which our minds work, that it actually changes the way they can actually perceive the conflict and perhaps respond differently. When people learn about these different biases, they're initially very optimistic that what we need to do is educate people about the biases. So if I just tell people, like my students, here's the different biases that people engage
还有我们对这些行为根源的信念，如果我们相信个人是有偏见的，他们的思维过程是有偏见的，那么我们就不相信试图和他们讲道理是有意义的。有没有任何证据表明，向人们传授我们大脑工作的方式，实际上会改变他们实际感知冲突的方式，并可能做出不同的反应？当人们了解这些不同的偏见时，他们最初非常乐观，认为我们需要做的是教育人们了解这些偏见。所以如果我只是告诉人们，比如我的学生，这里是人们经常陷入的各种偏见，
in, that that should solve the problem. They'll say, gee, I didn't know about all those biases. And the idea is now that I know about them, I won't do them. But as you know, that's not how it works. Because what happens is they say, gee, I didn't have words for all those biases. But now that you've told me the words, they give me a great vocabulary for describing what all these people around me keep doing. So that doesn't work. But what you cooked there and I tried was instead to educate people about the importance of unconscious processes. And we taught people about how a lot of our judgments are rooted in things we don't have access to so that a lot of things
这应该能解决问题。他们会说，天哪，我不知道所有这些偏见。他们的想法是，既然我知道了它们，我就不会再犯了。但如你所知，事情并不是这样的。因为发生的情况是他们会说，天哪，我以前没有词汇来形容所有这些偏见。但既然你告诉我了这些词汇，它们就给了我一个极好的词汇表，用来描述我周围所有这些人一直在做的事情。所以这不管用。但你刚才做的事以及我尝试过的是转而教育人们了解无意识过程的重要性。我们教导人们我们的许多判断是如何植根于我们无法接触的事物中的，因此许多事情
are automatic and a lot of things are biased. And so we tried to educate them about essentially the introspection illusion, the illusion that we have access to all these things, and the fact that instead much of it is occurring automatically and is biased, and then we asked people to complete our usual bias blind spot measure where they read about various biases, and then people no longer showed a bias blind spot. So once they understood about the operation of the unconscious and how these things happen automatically, they no longer claimed to be less biased than others. So then they said, gee, maybe I am biased, maybe looking inwards and not seeing bias is not the best way to conclude whether I am biased or not.
都是自动的，许多事情是有偏见的。所以我们试图教育他们基本上了解内省错觉，即我们能够接触到所有这些事物的错觉，以及相反，其中很大一部分是自动发生且带有偏见的现象，然后我们要求人们完成我们通常的偏见盲点测量，他们阅读了各种偏见，然后人们不再表现出偏见盲点。因此，一旦他们了解了无意识的运作以及这些事情是如何自动发生的，他们就不再声称自己比别人更没有偏见。所以他们会说，天哪，也许我确实有偏见，也许向内看却没有看到偏见并不是判断我是否有偏见的最佳方式。
way to conclude whether I'm biased or not. Can you give me a concrete example of a time when you used your own research to change how you thought about something important or to change your own behavior? I don't know if I can give you a single important example, but I think that as a parent, I find it happening with me all the time that, you know, I'm talking to my kids about someone in our lives who's done something that sort of has, you know, I'm talking to my kids about someone in our lives who's done something that sort of has, you know, irritated us in some way. You know, somebody canceled on a plan that we had or, you know, said something that, you know, was insensitive and, and I find myself, you know, doing that thing right where I'm
判断我是否有偏见的方法。你能给我一个具体的例子吗？在那个例子中，你用你自己的研究改变了你对某件重要事情的看法或改变了你自己的行为？我不知道我能否给你举出一个重要的例子，但我认为作为一个父母，我发现这种情况一直在发生，你知道的，我正在和我的孩子们谈论我们生活中的某个人，这个人做了一些事情，你知道的，我正在和我们的孩子们谈论我们生活中的某个人，这个人做了一些事情，你知道的，以某种方式激怒了我们。你知道，有人取消了我们的计划，或者，你知道的，说了一些你知道的很不体贴的话，然后我发现自己，你知道的，做那件事，我
about to jump to the fundamental attributioner and I'm about to say, you know, gee, that was, you know, mean or inconsiderate or lazy or whatever, and then I've got my kids there with me. Oh, this is not what I want to teach my children. And so I say, wait a second, you know, I know what might seem like the person was being inconsiderate, but maybe we're having a really hard day. I tried to sort of teach them and to remind myself
快要跳到基本归因谬误上去了，我正要说，你知道的，天哪，那是，你知道的，卑鄙的、不体贴的、懒惰的或者别的什么，然后我的孩子们就在我身边。哦，这不是我想教给我孩子的东西。所以我说，等一下，你知道的，我知道这可能看起来那个人很不体贴，但也许我们正经历着非常艰难的一天。我试着教导他们，并提醒我自己
to think about people's circumstances instead of jumping right away to that Dispositional attribution You know Emily as I'm thinking about your work. I'm realizing that many miscommunications might happen Because our thoughts seem so clear to us, but we do a terrible job communicating those thoughts to others Things in our minds seem so clear and loom so large to us that we somehow assume they must be clear to others as well. Yeah, it's interesting.
去考虑人们的环境，而不是马上跳到那个性格归因。你知道，艾米丽，当我在思考你的工作时，我意识到许多沟通不畅可能会发生，因为我们的想法对我们自己来说是如此清晰，但我们在向他人传达这些想法时做得非常糟糕。我们脑海中的东西对我们来说似乎如此清晰，规模如此宏大，以至于我们不知何故认为它们对其他人来说也一定很清晰。是的，这很有趣。
I think of the example of breakups, romantic breakups, and people sort of, they want to be kind and they want to be considerate and they want to do it nicely, not always. And the other person is left totally confused and goes, oh, yeah, I think we're just taking a break for a few days, or we just hit a rough patch. And the other person thinks they have successfully broken up
我想到了分手的例子，浪漫的分手，人们某种程度上，他们想要表现得善良，他们想要体贴，他们想要好好地结束，并不总是这样。而另一个人则完全糊涂了，说，哦，是的，我想我们只是休息几天，或者我们只是遇到了一个坎。而另一个人认为他们已经成功分手了
and ended their relationship. But we forget that our intentions, what we're intending to do is to break up, to close the door, but to do it in a very kind and considerate way. And what the other person thinks is that you've sent a bunch of mixed messages and you're leaving the door open. This is just one of so many examples where we don't recognize our lack of transparency
并结束了他们的关系。但我们忘记了我们的意图，我们打算做的是分手，是关上这扇门，但要以一种非常善良和体贴的方式去做。而另一个人认为你发送了一堆矛盾的信息，你还在敞开大门。这只是我们没有意识到我们缺乏透明度的众多例子之一，
and what we haven't communicated because it's so obvious to us. I don't know if you're a fan of the show Parks and Recreation, but there was an incident on Parks and Rec that basically is almost exactly the same line, so one party is breaking up with another, but they break up so politely and so kindly of the other party things. Great. We've had a wonderful chat. The relationship is now on to a higher level than it was before. And one party thinks they're broken up with the other party things.
以及我们没有传达的东西，因为它对我们来说太明显了。我不知道你是不是《公园与游憩》这部剧的粉丝，但《公园与游憩》中发生了一起事件，基本上台词几乎完全一样，所以一方和另一方分手了，但他们分手得如此礼貌和亲切，以至于另一方认为。太棒了。我们进行了一次愉快的交谈。这段关系现在上升到了比以前更高的水平。其中一方认为他们已经分手了，而另一方则认为。
Wow. We're really on a good place now. So you're leaving soon. Back to Indianapolis briefly and then onto a town called Snurling, Indiana for several months. Never heard of it. It's quite small. The cows at number the people 41.
哇。我们现在真的在一个好地方了。所以你要走了。短暂回到印第安纳州，然后去印第安纳州一个叫斯纳林的小镇几个月。没听说过。它相当小。这里的牛比人多41只。
And then after Chris moves and tracks him down, storms into his house and accuses him of cheating on her. God. I'm so sorry, honey. I'm so embarrassed. I was scared that you were cheating on me. No, I'm cheating on you. But I'm also not dating you.
然后克里斯搬家后，她追踪到他，冲进他的房子，指责他背叛了她。天哪。我很抱歉，亲爱的。我很尴尬。我害怕你背叛了我。不，我背叛了你。但我也不是在跟你约会。
We broke up last week. Yeah, I'm laughing, but it's actually sad. I mean, it actually causes a lot of suffering in reality. Yeah. We've just been through a really bruising political year, Emily, and the country as a whole has been very divided. And a lot of people are really asking, is it possible for us to come together as a nation after very bitter political fight?
我们上周就分手了。是的，我在笑，但其实这很悲伤。我的意思是，它在现实中实际上造成了许多痛苦。是的。我们刚刚经历了一个非常痛苦的政治年份，艾米丽，整个国家一直非常分裂。很多人都在真诚地问，经历了一场非常痛苦的政治斗争后，我们作为国家有可能重新团结在一起吗？
I'm wondering if you were to give advice to the nation based on the work that you have done, what would that advice look and sound like? I mean, I think one thing I would say is that if you were judging yourself by all your positive intentions, right, and you're good feelings, you know, if your intentions are that you want the country to be in a better place, that you want people to thrive, don't assume that others intentions are different from your own. And if you put a lot of weight on your intentions, those others intentions would deserve just that same amount of weight. So we owe some charity in judging
我想知道，如果你根据你所做的工作给国家提出建议，这个建议会是什么样的，听起来会是怎样的？我的意思是，我想我会说的一件事是，如果你用你所有的积极意图来评判你自己，对吧，还有你的良好感觉，你知道的，如果你的意图是你希望国家变得更好，你希望人们繁荣发展，不要假设别人的意图与你不同。如果你对你的意图赋予了很大的权重，那么那些别人的意图也应该得到同样多的权重。所以在评判时我们应该保持一些宽容
others' behavior by giving some weight to their intentions, and we should not assume that their intentions are so different from our own. And if we can start with that and start with the charity of trying to find the positive intentions and others, then maybe there is some hope, but it's so hard to do, especially when things are so divided. And feel so divided. Psychologist Emily Pronen teaches at Princeton University. Emily, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. having me.
通过给他们的意图赋予一定的权重来对待他人的行为，我们不应该假设他们的意图与我们自己的有那么大不同。如果我们能从这一点开始，并以试图找到积极意图的宽容态度对待他人，那么也许还有一些希望，但这很难做到，尤其是当一切都如此分裂的时候。并且感觉如此分裂。心理学家艾米丽·普罗嫩在普林斯顿大学任教。艾米丽，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Mid-Roll Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Max Lenowitz. Max is an onboarding manager at JustWorks, the company that handles payroll for Hidden Brain Media. Max worked closely with us as we were
《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒制作。Mid-Roll Media是我们独家广告销售合作伙伴。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是马克斯·列诺维茨。马克斯是JustWorks的入职经理，这家公司负责处理《隐藏的大脑》传媒的薪资。马克斯在我们
launching our company and he patiently answered our many questions about how to pay employees and track things like vacation and sick time. His good cheer made a busy time feel less stressful. Thank you Max for helping us to find our feet. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter or at hiddenbrain.org. If you like today's show and like our program, please be sure to share it with a friend. If they don't know how to subscribe to our podcast, please show them. I'm Shankar Vidantum. See you next week.
创立公司时与我们紧密合作，他耐心地回答了我们关于如何支付员工薪资以及追踪度假和病假等事宜的许多问题。他开朗的精神让忙碌的时光感觉没那么大压力。谢谢马克斯帮助我们站稳脚跟。有关更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，您可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们，或访问hiddenbrain.org。如果你喜欢今天的节目并喜欢我们的节目，请务必与朋友分享。如果他们不知道如何订阅我们的播客，请教教他们。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。下周见。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你 这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。